مع تطورات السودان قال مسؤولون تعليمي
سوداني للجزيره ان نحو
خمسين طالبا
وتلميذا محتجزون منذ الصباح في مدرسه
كامبوني بالخرطوم قرب مسرح القتال معنى من
مدرسه كمبوني في العاصمه السودانيه
الاستاذ شاكر اسحاق المدرس في المدرسه
والمحتجز بداخل المدرسه مع الطلاب
سيد شاكر
ما الذي ما الذي يحصل حولكم وكيف هو وضعكم
وماذا تريد ان تقول
الوضع حول المدرسه سيئه جدا
ضرب من كل الاتجاهات بعد تسقط في داخل
المدرسه حتى اصيب طالب في ظهره بالرصاصه
طائشه هو الان بخير لم نجد اي او اي شيء
قمنا بالاساف هذا الاوليه من داخل المدرسه
هذا كله ما في الامر لا يوجد اي اعانيات
للطلاب
للمناوله وهما الان في اوضاع مزرعه جدا
يعني حتى الان
اشتباكات حول المدرسه
من المدرسه
لا يبعد عن خمسين متر لا يبعد عن 100 او
200 متر فالقرب من المدرسه
نحن نسمع اطلاق رصاص صحيح
هذا بالقرب من المدرسه
بعد المدرسه
يعني شمال قصر الجمهوري وايضا قريبون من
مقر القياده العامه وتدور نعم وتدور
اشتباكات وانتم محتجزون منذ الصباح
منذ صباح من
هناك احد الطلاب
اصيب بالرصاص في ظهره
وليست هناك اماكن امنه داخل المدرسه
للاحتماء من من الرصاصه والقذائف
الطلاب في الحجره الداخليه
التحتيه في البنيه التحتيه
القوف الاكبر هي من الحيوانات التي تاتي
من بين الغازات التي تسقط بالقرب من
المدرسه حتى اصيب مبنى المدير العام لكليه
كمبروني الابوني
في الكليه الاساسيه وهي يصلنا عن طريق
ايضا
الاوضاع ليس في امان لا لا يحدث عدد
الطلاب المحتجزين واعمار هؤلاء الطلاب
في الثانوي الاعمار 14 الى 20 25 سنه
حادثه اما في الاساس من الى 15
هو عددهم حوالي 250
250 ثانوي فقط انما في الاساس ايضا عدد
يعني انت تتحدث يعني انت تتحدث عن حوالي
من مدرستان
والجميع والجميع محتجزون الجميع محتجزون
حول 450 من الطلاب
طب هل جرى التواصل مع اي
طرف من اجل تخفيف حده الاشتباكات لاخلائهم
لم لم يجرى اي شيء حتى الان نحن في انتظار
الحدودنا من ثم تنظر ماذا سيحدث يوم غد
فقط سؤال كيف يتدبر الطلاب امورهم في
موضوع الماكل
والمشرب خصوصا انك تقول انه منذ الصباح
محاصرون داخل
ومحتجزون في هذه المدرسه
لم يتناول شيء ما عدا الفاتوره التي ياتي
به من منازلهم هذا ما تناولوه غاز فقط
والان يعيشون على
يعيشون على الماء
هذا كل ما في الامر حتى المعلمين المدرسين
في نفس الاوضاع
لا يتناول شيء حتى الذين كانوا صائمون لم
يجد شيء لا يتناوله غير النار مباشره لا
شيء اخر
شاكر اسحاق المدرس في مدرسه كامبوني
بالخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من داخل
المدرسه
المحاصره اذا صح التعبير
بالقصف والاشتباكات